una de las ideas más fundamentales en la
física es el concepto de trabajo lo voy
a poner aquí trabajo y la fórmula que
nos dan en la secundaria para trabajo es
fuerza por distancia pero después en
prepa nos damos cuenta que pues hay
ciertas cosas vectoriales por ahí
metidas y entonces la fuerza no siempre
va en la misma dirección que el
desplazamiento entonces tenemos que
adaptar nuestra fórmula y nos queda algo
nuevo nos queda la magnitud de la fuerza
la magnitud de la fuerza d
la fuerza pero nada más de la fuerza que
va en la dirección
la dirección
del desplazamiento y recuerda que esto
del desplazamiento simplemente es
distancia con alguna dirección entonces
en la dirección del desplazamiento y
ahora si eso de ahí multiplicado por la
magnitud del desplazamiento o
simplemente la distancia por la
distancia el ejemplo clásico que se ve
cuando cuando uno habla de esta fórmula
es el ejemplo de digamos un bloque de
hielo voy a ponerlo por aquí que está
descansando sobre una superficie plana
esto de la superficie plana es para
poder suponer que no hay fricción y
entonces jalamos ese hielo con una
fuerza algo de este estilo aquí lo voy a
poner
efe y vamos a suponer que la fuerza es
igual a bueno no en realidad no la
fuerza sino vamos a suponer que la
magnitud de la fuerza voy a ponerlo así
la magnitud de la fuerza es igual a 10
newtons también tenemos que dar un
ángulo vamos a suponer que la dirección
de la fuerza tiene un ángulo lo voy a
marcar por aquí un ángulo de 30 no mejor
de 60
con respecto a la horizontal entonces
esta es la dirección en la cual estoy
jalando y supongamos que tenemos
desplazamiento hacia la derecha a ver
voy a poner por aquí una flecha para
marcar que estamos moviendo el hielo
hacia la derecha y vamos a suponer que
esto es un desplazamiento de 5 metros o
sea que la magnitud del desplazamiento
es igual a 5
metros
ahora no podemos simplemente multiplicar
la magnitud de la fuerza que es 10
newtons por la magnitud del
desplazamiento que 5 metros y obtener la
el trabajo que tenemos porque así no
funciona el trabajo cuando hay
direcciones lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar la magnitud de la fuerza que
va en la misma dirección que el
desplazamiento entonces voy a marcar
esto de aquí
esto mide 10 y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar de esa fuerza total
cuánto va en la misma dirección que el
desplazamiento o sea hacia acá para eso
tenemos que usar trigonometría este
cuando metía muy simple nos queda 10
veces el coste no de 60 grados 10 por
coseno de 60 grados coseno de 60 es un
medio entonces es 10 por un medio que es
igual a 5 ok entonces esta magnitud de
la fuerza que va hacia la derecha es
igual a 5 newtons aquí lo pongo 5
newtons y ahora sí ya teniendo la
magnitud en ese sentido vamos a ponerle
que el trabajo es igual a 5 newtons
multiplicado por la distancia lo voy a
poner por a ver la magnitud de estos
cinco metros nos queda 25 newton metros
o lo que es lo mismo veinticinco lluís
de trabajo
sale todo esto de aquí es algo pues más
o menos como un repaso pero vamos a
pensar en términos más abstractos para
después hablar de otras cosas entonces
el trabajo nos queda 5 newtons que venía
de la magnitud de la fuerza
voy a ponerle aquí la magnitud de la
fuerza y eso de ahí x el coseno de este
ángulo vamos a llamarle theta para
hacerlo en general entonces nos queda
coseno de teta esto de aquí es la
cantidad de la fuerza en la dirección
del desplazamiento y luego eso de ahí
tenemos que multiplicarlo por la
magnitud del desplazamiento por la
magnitud del desplazamiento
vamos a reacomodar esto un poco lo voy a
poner como la magnitud del
desplazamiento multiplicado por la
magnitud de la fuerza multiplicado por
el coste no de teta y aquí debemos
empezar a sospechar que ya es un
concepto que habíamos visto en otros
vídeos de álgebra lineal de física y de
algunos productos vectoriales hablé del
producto punto y fíjate que justo esto
de aquí es el producto punto de de con
efe es decir es igual a tres puntos efe
sale entonces en general si queremos
encontrar el trabajo para un
desplazamiento y una fuerza constantes
simplemente debemos tomar el producto
punto de esos dos vectores si se te hace
muy raro esto del producto punto creo
que deberías checar los vídeos
anteriores que hice al respecto porque
ahí se habla muy bien de la intuición
pero para no dejar del lado del lado así
tan feo esto voy a hablar un poco de la
intuición cuando hacemos de punto efe lo
que nos dice es más o menos que tanto
bueno esto de acá es esto mismo de acá
déjame ponerlo en otras palabras la idea
es que estamos tomando cuánto de este
vector está en la dirección de este otro
vector en este ejemplo lo marcamos aquí
y luego multiplicamos las dos magnitudes
es justo lo que hacemos aquí verdad el
trabajo es la fuerza punto
el vector de desplazamiento esto de aquí
nos queda un valor escalar vamos a hacer
algunos ejemplos después donde veas que
eso es cierto pero bueno todo esto de
aquí simplemente fue un repaso de pues
de física de prepa va vamos a algo un
poco más complejo que en el fondo tiene
la misma idea vamos a definir primero
que es un campo vectorial entonces un
campo vectorial va a ser una función
vamos a llamarle efe que depende de una
equis y una y es decir es una función en
el plano xy y es igual a una función
escalar de xy multiplicada por el vector
unitario y
y luego le tenemos que sumar otra
función de escalar q de xy
multiplicada por el vector vertical
unitario es decir el vector j cómo se
vería algo de este estilo primero déjame
ponerle un nombre esto de aquí es un
campo vectorial en dos dimensiones vamos
a ponerle campo vectorial
en el plano xy o bien le puedes poner en
2 no me quiero meter mucho en detalles
matemáticos en vez de eso mejor vamos a
hacer un dibujo para entender este
concepto voy a dibujar los ejes a ver
algo así no no no a ver algo un poco más
derechito algo así
al parecer tengo problemas de dibujar
una línea recta
ahí está el eje y el eje x aquí solo
dibuje el primer cuadrante pero en
realidad puede seguir t hacia los
valores negativos si así lo deseas y
entonces qué hace esto esto
esencialmente nos dice nos das una equis
nos das una ye y con eso nosotros
podemos encontrar unos números que vamos
a multiplicar por el vector i y acá
vamos a obtener algo por el vector j y
entonces vamos a tener una combinación
lineal del vector i y el vector j es
decir vamos a tener un vector lo que
esto hace es definir un vector en cada
uno de los puntos del plano x entonces
puedes tomar este punto de aquí digamos
nos da algunos números en la expresión
de aquí arriba
y lo que lo que acabamos teniendo es un
vector
eso de ahí lo podemos hacer en
cualquiera de los puntos si tomamos un
punto por acá vamos a obtener otro
vector un tercer punto nos va a dar un
tercer vector otro punto más nos va a
dar otro vector y así podemos seguir
indefinidamente en realidad aquí estoy
tomando algunos puntos aleatorios para
dibujar todo tendríamos que dibujar en
cada uno de los puntos del plano x sale
entonces ahí tenemos otro más por ahí
tenemos otro más y cuál es la idea
física detrás de todo esto pues la idea
física es que en cada uno de los puntos
tenemos una cierta fuerza aplicada que
está dada por un cierto vector déjame
dibujar unos cuantos más en realidad
podría seguir haciendo esto pues
indefinidamente verdad pero creo que ves
la idea en cada uno de los puntos
tenemos que poner una flechita un vector
pues ahora porque se llama campo
vectorial
pues porque generaliza muchos tipos de
campos que aparecen en la física campos
magnéticos campos gravitacionales campos
eléctricos etcétera y entonces esto
esencialmente nos dice cuántas fuerzas
se aplica en una partícula
en cada campo bueno vamos a suponer que
en este campo ahora tenemos una
partícula que se va moviendo vamos a
marcarla por aquí vamos a suponer que la
partícula
empieza en este punto y que
independientemente de todas estas
flechas que hay la partícula empieza a
moverse con una cierta trayectoria
física déjame dibujar la partícula a lo
mejor la partícula no se mueve en la
dirección que diga el campo vectorial
puede irse por acá y terminar en este
punto
y vamos a suponer que esta trayectoria
está definida por pues por una
parametrización digamos del estilo r que
depende de una variable de un cierto
tiempo y vamos a ponerle x dt x y sumado
con 7 x j ok eso de ahí es el dt que nos
da una parametrización de nuestra
trayectoria vamos a acotar t entre a
vamos a ponerle a menor o igual que t y
menor o igual que b para que nuestra
trayectoria nos quede una línea finita
entonces esto es una trayectoria que la
partícula empieza a recorrer y además
tenemos que considerar las fuerzas que
van aplicando se van aplicando sobre
esta partícula aquí tenemos una cierta
fuerza hacia allá luego la partícula se
empieza a mover pero en este punto puede
ser que haya otra fuerza del campo
vectorial aplicada y se va a seguir
moviendo ahora todo lo que he hecho en
este vídeo es para caer en una pregunta
fundamental cuál es el trabajo total
aplicado por el campo vectorial sobre la
partícula lo voy a poner por aquí
es el trabajo total va entonces el
trabajo total aplicado en la partícula
esa es la pregunta que queremos
responder vamos a dibujar un pequeño
cachito de nuestra trayectoria imagínate
que estamos aquí aplicando una
amplificación y supongamos que queremos
encontrar cuál es el trabajo que se hace
en una parte muy muy muy chiquita fíjate
que hay muchas cosas cambiando es como
muy dinámico todo esto pero en un punto
aquí vamonos algo puntual supongamos que
nos movemos algo muy muy muy pequeñito
eso te recuerda algo si ponemos deere
pues tiene que ver con diferenciales o
sea dada nuestra parametrización esto lo
que nos dice es que nos estamos moviendo
algo muy pequeño sobre la trayectoria
ahora cuando hacemos este pequeño cambio
en esta zona de aquí tenemos una fuerza
del campo vectorial actuando sobre la
partícula esta de aquí le vamos a poner
f evaluado en ese punto
y entonces fíjate aquí tenemos un cambio
infinitesimal en la dirección y aquí
tenemos una fuerza que está siendo
aplicada en ese punto cuál va a ser el
trabajo hecho en este pequeño lugar es
decir cuál es el pequeño cambio en el
trabajo vamos a ponerle wv para usar
notación diferencial pero justo por lo
que trabajamos acá arriba tenemos la
magnitud de la fuerza en la dirección de
este desplazamiento multiplicado por la
magnitud del desplazamiento es una y ya
sabemos que es vamos a regresar aquí
arriba para acordarnos como dije es el
producto punto entonces hay que hacer el
producto punto de la fuerza y nuestro
cambio infinitesimal eso de ella es
igual a la fuerza punto
de r es decir nuestro pequeño cambio en
el movimiento de la partícula ahora
cuando estamos haciendo eso es encontrar
el trabajo pero en un pues en un cachito
super super pequeño pero lo que queremos
hacer es sumar todos todos todos estos
cambios hay una infinidad de estos
entonces esto nos tiene que recordar una
vez más otro concepto cuando aparecen
sumas infinitas pues cuando hacemos una
integral entonces vamos a hacer una
integral de línea de qué cosa pues aquí
tenemos un de w
pero sobre que la hacemos pues sobre c
sobre la trayectoria está de acá vamos a
llamarle c y qué cosa tenemos que
integrar tenemos que hacer la integral
de wv eso de ahí nos va a dar el trabajo
total el trabajo es igual a eso pero
también es igual a la integral sobre la
misma curva de f punto de r y entonces
aquí me puede decir oye esto esto la
verdad pues no me va a servir mucho
porque está súper abstracto como le
puedo hacer para realmente calcular el
trabajo en la partícula esta expresión
de aquí
pero ya en términos de té o con algo más
concreto
pues déjame contarte eso vas a ver que
nos va a quedar una expresión un poco
más evaluable por así decirlo entonces
que ese efe punto de ere a ver vamos a
acordarnos que quería decir de r
entonces vamos a escribir aquí de r dt
es igual a
x prima de té también puede haber puesto
de x dt pero como x es una variable lo
pongo aquí por y x prima de t x j
ahora si simplemente queremos de r pues
podemos multiplicar por desde aquí estoy
siendo como que un poco pues no sé cómo
que práctico pero no rigurosa entonces
nos queda aquí es prima de tdt por i + d
prima de t por de t por el vector j
sale entonces ya tenemos una expresión
para leer ahora esta expresión para de r
queremos hacerle producto punto con qué
cosa pues con efe y el campo vectorial
de acá arriba déjame copiar y pegar la
para que podamos trabajar mejor entonces
vamos a copiar y vamos a ver que no nos
queda tan alocado el producto punto lo
voy a pegar aquí cómo le hacemos para
hacer el producto punto de estas dos
cosas pues fíjate el producto punto
justo lo calcula vamos coordenada
coordenada lo que hacíamos era
multiplicar las coordenadas en cada una
de las entradas y sumamos las dos cosas
entonces aquí el de ere y el f están
justo en la forma en la cual podemos
hacerlo nos queda la integral de qué
cosa bueno voy a poner aquí de igual a
igual a ver porque es el el intervalo en
el cual se mueve t y ya queremos pasar
todo a a simplemente la variable t
entonces bajemos
y tenemos que hacer el producto punto d
efe punto de r lo que te decía se puede
calcular muy fácilmente a partir de la
definición del producto punto porque
simplemente tenemos que multiplicar las
entradas en la primera coordenada y
luego sumarle el producto de las
segundas coordenadas entonces nos queda
el producto de px ahí va estoy copiando
el vamos a ponerle x dt porque x ya está
en función de t
esa es esta expresión por equis prima de
t de t va estamos multiplicando la
primera entrada la entrada
correspondiente allí x prima de t de t
y luego tenemos que sumar
tenemos que sumar lo que nos queda de
las segundas entradas es decir vámonos a
la q lo voy a poner un poquito aquí
abajo porque ya se me está acabando el
espacio y no quiero recorrer la pantalla
q de x dt 7 y eso de ahí multiplicado
por la componente de aquí del de r es
prima para ponerle prima de t de t ahora
lo mejor me digas oye tienes que estar
bromeando la verdad esto aquí sigue
siendo muy abstracto pero pero no es
cierto esto de aquí ya todo está en
términos de t entonces ésta de aquí es
una integral simple y sencilla con
respecto a t de las que ya hemos hecho
miles y miles de ellas entonces estoy
aquí ya nos va a permitir trabajar esta
expresión de aquí ya nos va a permitir
trabajar con algunos ejemplos más
concretos nos vemos entonces en los
siguientes vídeos para encontrar algunas
integrales de línea en campos
vectoriales